we started dots two years ago and my
co-founder Patrick had this idea to
create an art inspired game a game that
we wanted to play my name is Paul Murphy
I'm one of the cofounders of dots and
I'm the CEO with on stats and we had a
lot of downloads millions of people
started playing this game it was a
little bit overwhelming and we had a lot
of feature requests my name is Ben
Rodman I'm the visual designer on two
dots at dots one of the hardest
challenges has been trying to find that
sweet spot between functionality and fun
at the same time from a UI perspective
there's certain communication that has
to be conveyed so people know what
they're doing my name is Christian
Calderon the head of marketing at dots
early on some of the qualitative
measures that we would look at in the
game is just how people would react to
holding the phone and connecting dots
the challenge with that is it's not
scalable to do that over 70 different
countries with millions and millions of
players my name is Tony Haney I'm a data
scientist at dance Google Play
experiments is kind of a one-stop
service which enable us to upload
different marketing assets icons
screenshots copy that goes goes with
those and optimize the directions that
we go those Google Playstore experiments
have helped us in two main ways
one is had a impact on helping us really
understand how changes that we may
impact user behavior our control the
icon that we had currently in the game
at a white background and we tested that
with a another icon I had a black
background what we realized was that the
icon with white background just
performed a lot better the second is
just the impact of the business we
tested many different things with our
screenshots the two largest ones were
illustrating gameplay graphically also
illustrating gameplay with text what we
noticed was that together they had a
compound effect positive effect on
conversion of about 8% when use
localized the experiments help us become
smarter at what we do it also has a
business impact it is very easy to use
you don't need to implement those
analytical tracking
you don't need to worry about
segmentation all those things will be
done automatically the advice I'd give
other developers is to always seek
knowledge ever stop trying to learn new
things don't be afraid to make mistakes
and to learn from them plan with dots is
to continue making dots based games
we've created a mechanic that we think
is unique very creative lead we find the
creativity we find the fun and then we
try to layer on the business aspects
afterwards